you guys loved yesterday's fall of x
video so let's cover the Iron Man
Prelude where he fights a 50-foot tall
X-Men Buster suit and the question's got
to be asked why is he fighting an Iron
Man Sentinel designed to kill mutants
okay why the clock back because this is
the fault of both a guy named feilong
and Tony Stark himself so this opens up
with Tony Stark in his Brownstone
apartment and by all standards of
measurement he's basically broke why
because in a story leading up to this
Tony Stark had Tracked Down what was
called Source control it was basically a
black market arms dealer organization
but in order to ensure that those arms
and Armament couldn't be sold out on the
open market he ended up using most of
his money to buy it all up and then
dismantle it what little money he has
left is about to disappear because while
he's in this Brownstone somebody
sabotaged his Arc Reactor and blows the
whole place to Pieces not only that it
kills his neighbor so now his entire
reputation is tarnished not only that
when he meets with Jennifer Walter
She-Hulk who's kind of lawyer for the
superhero Community she initially tells
them that the family of the woman is
suing him but so are a whole bunch of
people who claim to be around the
building or in the building and they're
all mostly frivolous lawsuits and while
it would take a lot of time to sort
through it all and she could basically
reduce things down to where he's only
being sued by the woman of the family
not only that he's also being sued by
all these people who are basically
filing frivolous lawsuits but an effort
to make it all go away he takes what
little money he has left and just tells
Jennifer Walters pay them all off so now
he has basically nothing and so he ends
up basically taking up residence inside
of just some old mechanic's shop and
like that's it but the big question that
has to be asked here is who did this who
caused this in the first place well for
the most part any lead out there is
virtually non-existent and the best
thing he has to go on is some random
villain out there who just starts
launching an attack Tony Starks able to
defeat this guy but when he rips his
mask off he realizes it's a guy who's
been kidnapped and has been missing for
two days the problem with this is he
takes a momentary reprieve to go to his
Alcoholics Anonymous meeting because
Tony Stark's an alcoholic in the comics
but then he passes out only to wake up
in Hell's Kitchen New York now he is
rescued by Riri Williams and between the
two of them they start talking over
what's going on who's coming after Tony
Stark and she agrees almost
wholeheartedly Tony didn't blow up his
own Brownstone and whoever this villain
is that's operating behind the scenes
certainly has some kind of Vendetta form
but then the Living Laser just kind of
appears out of nowhere and starts
attacking the city now the Living Laser
has historically been a minor villain of
Tony Stark not the most important
character there ever was but he is
important to this story and the reason
why is because he claims Tony Stark came
after him attacked him subdued him and
then started experimenting on him now
Stark has no clue what he's talking
about right he's like I have not seen
you in forever and while you are
certainly a villain that should be taken
seriously kind of sometimes I guess I'm
not the guy who kidnapped you but as far
as a Living Laser is concerned it's true
Tony Stark went after him now at this
point in time in Marvel Comics Riri
Williams has the ten rings of the
Mandarin and while they do have or at
least Grant her a variety of powers for
the sake of this discussion one of the
things it does is it allows her to read
and project the mind of the Living Laser
and when she projects his own memories
out to Tony Stark for him to see and
even for her to see they come to the
realization Tony Stark really did come
after him he really did attack him but
it wasn't actually Tony Stark it was
someone who looked like Tony Stark and
so following this we pick up with what
appears to be the assassination of a guy
named zhongwei who's zong Wei zhongwei
was at one point and even to this day
still remained a friend of Tony Stark he
was brought on to Stark Industries
relatively early the two of them have
been working together for an incredibly
long time here's the kicker to all of
this when Tony Stark was kicked out of
his own company due to the Brownstone
explode ocean and lost all of his money
between a combination of source control
as well as paying all the people off who
were suing him basically zhongwei had
control of Stark Industries he owned the
most stock in the company and the Bucks
stopped there but with him being killed
now there's no one to run Stark
Industries and so jumping back to Tony
Stark and his hunt for basically whoever
it was that looks like him and went
after him due to his intelligence he
figures out pretty fast it has to be a
life model decoy now for those of you
guys who don't know what that is in
Marvel Comics a life model decoy is
basically either a full-on robot or an
Android that looks like another human
being Nick Fury used those things all
the time but Tony Stark realizes there's
a life model decoy out there that's been
designed to look like him and to
basically go after certain people when
him and James Rhodes who he'd contacted
for help when they tracked down where
this life model decoy is located this
thing but that of a holding facility
basically wearing Ironman and armor and
between the two of them it's a full out
knock down brawl right I mean literally
the buildings getting demolished the
whole place is popping off but Tony
Stark stops him pretty fast just because
it's an Iron Man suit and he knows
exactly how those things work but when
he freezes the suit and he rips the
helmet off his suspicions are confirmed
it is a life model decoy now it does
taunt him for a little bit and it's
really speaking to him but it's more
like a recorded message somebody
speaking through this life model decoy
it must be so strange for you to hear me
speak with your own voice you spared
many lies by discovering this lab before
I revealed it tomorrow I'll admit you
were so slow out of the gate that I was
worried you'd be yet another boring
disappointment so basically this person
operating behind the scenes controlling
this life model decoy taking these pot
shots at Tony Stark and trying to
destroy his life they know who he is so
the question has to be asked who in the
world is it now of course shortly after
revealing this dragon antic message the
life model decoy effectively detonates
and starts to explode so of course Tony
Stark and James Rhodes have to get out
of there as fast as they possibly can
only for us to switch over to the person
who's actually behind all of this which
turns out to be a guy named FEI Long so
sidetracked from this story for a second
who in the world is feylon so FEI long
has historically been an X-Men villain
and he's a relatively new addition to
Marvel Comics he's only been around for
a couple years but the idea behind FEI
Long is that his origin ties directly
into Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers from 2013 which is to say
during that storyline Mars was
terraformed by basically some people out
there that we don't need to go into and
it was turned into a world that could
become habitable FEI Long basically led
a human research group that would take
this terraformed Mars and turn it into a
place that Humanity could colonize such
as it was all that went belly up when it
was effectively abandoned so all the
money he had invested had basically just
been thrown away and he largely blamed
the Avengers for it now where his
follow-up was to travel back to Mars and
simply just terraform the planet itself
due to the fact that feilong's so
incredibly intelligent by that point in
time a portion of the mutant population
on Earth had transitioned to Mars why
does that matter because if you're
following the X-Men Comics you know that
the mutant population lives on krakowa
they're their own country so when some
of them went to Mars Mars became an
extension of their own country it would
be like if the United States took over
Cuba and Cuba became part of the USA
Russia couldn't just go there and launch
a military Invasion without sparking a
war and that's what would have happened
if Fey long had showed up to Mars and
just started terraforming it it'd be
considered an invasion and an act of War
so all the money all the time all the
resources he had invested was all for
nothing and so ever since then he's
largely been an enemy of the X-Men the
other kicker behind behind all this is
FEI Long was responsible for the death
of zhongwei because when zhongwei was
killed all the stock he owned in Stark
Industries was dumped onto the open
market which feilong immediately bought
and now he is the one that runs Stark
Industries Stark doesn't even run his
own company anymore and so it's one of
the most methodical takeovers and
attacks on a superhero that exists out
there in Marvel Comics it's amazing but
when Tony Stark confronts this guy
they're surrounded by people cameras
everything and where it takes every
ounce of strength Tony Stark has not to
kill this guy at the end of the day he's
still able to keep himself calm to a
degree and even go so far as to say I
kind of admire your tenacity here guys
like Obadiah stain and Justin Hammer
never would have had the gumption to
pull off a stunt like this so there is
something to be said about your
intelligence understand this though if
the cameras were not here and if they
weren't surrounded by people Tony Stark
would probably beat this guy nearly to
death F and in fact he would kind of
have to stop himself or somebody would
have to step in it's a full-on vendetta
because not only is felon cost Tony
Stark everything that's important to him
he even went after Stark's friends and
family which even Stark himself says
that's something that stain and Justin
Hammer knew not to do you don't trifle
with the people who are close to me and
so where a fight breaks out between the
two of them FEI Long fires off this
massive energy blast from his own mouth
now the reason why he's able to do that
is because he basically gave himself
Powers that's one of the reasons why
he's pink but also why he has this
ability but for the most part the fight
between him and Stark while it seems
impressive isn't really all that
impressive it's more just kind of a
knock down drag out fist fight between
the two it's moderately interesting but
Tony Stark ultimately gets the upper
hand on this guy crushes his hand
literally breaks every single bone in
his hand and says here's what's going to
happen I'm going to give you to the rest
of the day but you're gonna go out there
into the world you're going to tell
everybody what you've done that you blew
up my Brownstone that you went after the
people that were closest to me you
killed my friend zong you are the one
that orchestrated all of this because at
this moment right now the destruction of
The Brownstone the death of Zhong way
from a Repulsor blast to the chest it's
all being viewed as the actions of Tony
Stark he is effectively the most wanted
man in the world right now but if they
long comes out and reveals his actions
and all of this it exonerates Stark life
can go it's close to back to normal as
it can be for a superhero on Earth and
then everything is more or less sorted
out of course feilong doesn't do any of
that because he's a villain and he does
what villains do what's bigger than this
though is that everything that is
related to Stark Industries is the
property of felon every facility every
piece of armor the whole nine yards and
so because all the Iron Man suits were
manufactured under Stark Industries
which could be basically make them a
business write-off now the Iron Man
suits belong to FEI Long on top of that
out in Texas in a air hanger right where
they store planes that belong to Stark
Industries they long finds this great
big huge cache of all these old
recordings from Howard Stark that were
made for Tony on a normal circumstances
that wouldn't matter for this story it
matters immensely specifically with
regards to the X-Men Buster suit the
reason for that and the reason why that
suits so powerful is that while we don't
necessarily get the ins and outs of what
happened what we find out is somewhere
along the line Howard Stark was working
alongside Adam Brashear the blue Marvel
one of the most intelligent and Powerful
beings in the entirety of Marvel Comics
and that between the two of them they
had discovered an element that did not
exist on the periodic table that element
is revealed to FEI Long by Howard Stark
where in reality it was simply just
supposed to be revealed to Tony but FEI
Long uses this information and then
starts bringing in all these metals from
all over the world directly to this
Hangar now Tony Stark picks up on this
and in fact he starts scanning the
manifests of Stark Industries to see if
anything strange and wonky is happening
because in his mind it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense that this guy
Fey long who's normally been a villain
of the X-Men would attack Tony Stark
sure Tony Stark's kind of a dick but in
reality it doesn't warrant the wholesale
destruction of his entire life so
something much bigger has to be going on
here FEI long has to be after the
resources of Stark not Stark himself and
so by analyzing the Import and Export
manifests of Stark Industries Tony Stark
realizes that all these medals have been
moved to this Hangar and when he gets in
there he comes face to face with a
50-foot tall Sentinel imbued and built
with Stark Tech and this Sentinel is
powered by whatever this mysterious
element happens to be now make no
mistake here Sentinels in Marvel Comics
are incredibly dangerous in Days of
Future Past they took over North America
wiped out most all humans and super
power beings alike and those who
survived were either thrown in
internment camps or living underground
as a kind of resistance force you're
talking about a traditional Sentinel
with that level of power that now has an
accompaniment of Stark Tech that
amplifies it even further not only that
FEI Long appears and then immediately
overpowers Tony Stark mostly because he
doesn't have his own Iron Man suit so
he's just there in his normal human form
just kind of being kicked around beat
around and that kind of a thing now
feilong does talk about this element
that's been discovered by Howard that's
being used in this suit but he doesn't
tell Tony Stark what it is so we don't
find out what it is suffice it to say he
says it is powerful enough that the
X-Men and the mutant population are
effectively dunzo right these guys are
over unless we forget the most powerful
beings in Marvel Comics across the board
are mutants which means this Sentinel
has to be equally powerful or at least
this Army of Sentinels have to be
comparable to the power of mutants
across the world and a full-on test of
what this thing can do happens when
felon sends it after Tony Stark he
literally puts Stark in his own suit and
says I want you to be at your best when
you see what this thing can do and it
absolutely annihilates Stark this guy
never had a chance not one chance
literally feilong says attack the
Intruder and it immediately goes after
Tony and all Tony can do firing off
Repulsor blasts left and right which
would normally be enough to take out any
kind of robot out there they just Zing
off this thing it's almost as if it's
bulletproof right it's incapable of
being harmed by the power of Iron Man so
the best Tony can do is just Flee for
his life while feilong watches him fly
away all the while amusing over the fact
that if Iron Man couldn't stop him what
chance do the X men have with that being
said guys we'll be back next Wednesday
with more fall of x if you guys need to
get caught up make sure you click this
playlist and I will catch you all later
peace